foreign
here's a backhander from Bastion that's blocked
in front didn't make it on sirokin Colin Miller
doesn't hop over his stick and Matt barzels Off to
the Races barzel on the break he scores [Applause]
Matt barzell puts the Islanders on top three
44 into this one well there was a bouncing
the Islanders blue line and Carla Miller
was caught a little flat-footed and it's
a little bit unfortunate he can't Corral that
puck that was bouncing barzel is able to skate
under it and come full bore on the Breakaway
and we talked about him having to have a good
offensive year for the alley in the near future
for this Devils team you know the cliche as the
game slows down for players as Engvall comes
in damage said the game doesn't feel slower
yet but he said he feels faster this year so
he thinks he can make those quicker decisions
pull out changes Direction gets it
down low to Engvall centering feet
score Brock Nelson Taps it in off a nice
sequence of passing from the Islanders
Devil's line and right here here the shot
Willman stick broke so he has to drop it
now Bullock ends up getting the puck back
and is able to make a little move gets it to
thing ball right there nobody ties
up Brock Nelson stick assistant coach
McGill used uh Graves and siegenthaler as well
as Mourinho so this is something you guys talked
about a little bit earlier about Kevin ball
really needed to step up here and show that
he can handle these minutes and if he can do
that there's a goal Sean Marino from the Blue
Line great RQ there guys gets the Devils on the
board and it's just good Hustle by Jack Hughes he
actually loses the drop but he hops around and
Emily retrieved the puck back gets it the ball
Quick Pass to Mourinho get in front of that you
gotta disrupt goaltenders as good as how the power
play looks Saturday night against the Rangers as
well they start with barzel corvat Nelson download
a Wall Street but it's a clean looking goal and
Schmidt got a piece of it right on the doorstep
as they enter the devil's own now though final
42nd to the power play ishikov
in front of his shot knocked away
I I thought the pace was really good and I'm
looking for guys to step in maybe earn jobs
win jobs but I think the most encouraging thing
you saw was was the camaraderie between the guys
like barzel and Horvat first unit out for the
Devils Now Jasper Bratt has it brat to Foley
Dowling Hughes and Hughes Jack across Brett scores
oh we've seen those two hook up so many times Jack
Hughes to Jasper Bratt [Applause] well that was an
absolute rocket of a one-timer a bomb from Jesper
Brad replay brought to you by the New Jersey
Lottery remember anything can happen in Jersey
and we saw this a little last year bill that
seam pass and Jack Hughes has the capabilities
to put it right in the Wheelhouse to Jasper
Bratton he blows it by throughout your career
oh look at that pass but horfat couldn't finish it
was dropped back to the blue line now the Devils
go two on one Jesper Bratz got it he shoots he
scores his second go in a matter of minutes and
the devil's lead [Music] a little Landing action
Islanders situation and the devil's zip it up ice
quick right to the Foley and look at the little
saw surpass all the subtle things you know the
veteran forward like the Foley and the speed of
just for brat just gets him back in the hole it
becomes a two-on-one and look at this quick
release he just hesitates and somehow finds
a little opening between the five hole all
that much if they didn't make those mistakes
early here's to Foley again flips it forward for
just for Brad Brad said one of the things that
is allowed to fully to fit so well with him and
Jack Hughes is he sees the liens that they see if
you think about Jack Hughes and just for breath
they're so creative but to fully season here's
Engvall the other way and he scores pouncing
on the loose Puck to tie the game at three
too many goals if he's got a wobbling Puck take
the shot right you see this Puck his replay goes
on it's on edge and for a goaltender you don't
know where it's going to come off the stick so
just a good idea with people closing in to get a
quick shot off and and that one found in the back
he has such a long powerful stride and Evans got
caught in between young defensiveness but that's
always an adjustment you got to figure out your
spacing so for him I think it's just getting his
feet wet and I'm not sure particularly oh how
about the Nifty works get it I'm saroken John
Marino's second today is that John Marino or
is it Jack Hughes you took the words right out
of my mouth I'm going yes he's got some offensive
ability but no more for his defensive stall where
he winds it up through the neutral zone and there
was that we're talking about physicality right
probably tried to go for the hit when he maybe
you play a little more stick on Puck there he
sort of got sort of got caught looked like he was
in between dude and these are not AHL goalies he
got Ilya Sorokin and Akira Schmid and the two
Nets tonight here's a chance in front Marino
put it over the bar looking for the hat-trick and
sirokin covers the most and from then on it's sort
of an uphill battle so I think for them that's got
to be the big Focus but so far there's been some
changes here's to Foley sliding it back extra
pass for brat moves it to Hughes and scores toe
how good it could that Trio be he's gonna
stop this wicked shot and as that puck is
tic-tac-toe is Right bill [Music] to Foley brat
and nemets all the touches on it before Hughes
puts it away you know a real heads up play by the
youngster Nemitz there with the One Touch pass
welcome back to Devil's hockey presented by
RWJ Barnabas helped the official healthcare
provider of the New Jersey Devils there is Kenneth
Appleby takes over for Ilyas sirokin who gave up
five goals on 18 shots but in saroka's defense
maybe one he could have saved if the devil's
just whipping pucks around making it very hard on
him oh there's a goal for the Islanders right out
of the shoot Matt barzell off the feed from
Bo Horvat it's 5-4 our owners cut the lead
by one two five four devils and they get
a step closer with the quick release and
there's the hit I'm talking about from Anders Lee
Horvat following up beautiful saucer passed John
Marino scored twice as the Blue Line Hughes
comes back to help sweep it away Mourinho
along the Dasher centers for Tivoli at ricochets
into the corner Kevin Ball settles it down there
Marina to the slot Bratz free again and he rips
it home it's a Jasper run pre-season hat trick
Under Pressure suddenly makes a little flip pass
to Mourinho it all was going well and that sets up
a wide open Brad as Mourinho gets that puck D to D
and finds Bratton he rips a wrister in one motion
past the glove hand of Appleby to give the Devils
a six more lead it's a four-point night for brat
three goals and an assisted three-point night now
for Mourinho two goals and an assist and Kevin
Ball picks up his second assist of the night as
well I mean Brad is just as they say time flies
it just doesn't feel right and he's still alive
yeah you started 18 years old you get those five
years pretty quickly yeah I guess you're right
Bill aho off a deflection and in not sure Schmidt
ever saw it it's a one goal game as Sebastian Ajo
scores schools in this hockey game still 337 left
time for the owners to try to get the equalizer
but they get that loose Puck up front and yeah
andersley you see him he's as good as it
gets it changing directions of pucks and
he gets a piece of that I want to see if
he gets it when they stick one more look
at it or it hits them oh yeah that's just
a great redirection final three seconds
Islanders need to get on side Horvat
flips it forward and there is the horn
oh that was fun how about 70 plus
more of those moving forward this year